[Music]
in 1948 Spanish ophthalmologist Jose
Ignacio Baraka Damona was fed up with
glasses he wanted a solution for blurry
vision that fixed the eye itself without
relying on external aids but the surgery
he eventually devised was not for the
faint of heart
bata care began by slicing off the front
of a patient's cornea and dunking it in
liquid nitrogen
using a miniature lathe he ground the
frozen cornea into the precise shape
necessary to focus the patients vision
then he thought the disc and sewed it
back on ba Decatur called this procedure
keratomileusis from the Greek words for
carving and cornea and though it might
sound grisly his technique produced
reliable results so how did ba Decatur
surgery work keratomileusis corrects
what are called refractive errors
imperfections in the way the eye focuses
incoming light ideally the cornea and
lens work together to focus light on the
surface of the retina but several kinds
of refractive errors can impair this
delicate system in people with myopia or
shortsightedness a steep cornea focuses
light just short of the retina those
with hyperopia or farsightedness have
the opposite problem light is focused
too far beyond the retina and in people
with astigmatism the cornea has two
different curvatures which focus light
at two distances and produce blurry
vision even those with perfect vision
will eventually suffer from presbyopia
or aging eyes as the proteins in the
lens age they slowly increase its size
by an adult's mid-40s the lens is too
large to easily change shape and shift
focus glasses and contact lenses bend
light to compensate for these refractive
errors but as bada cares procedure shows
we can also alter the shape
of the cornea its seller moving the
focal point backwards forwards or
pulling a divided image together
and thankfully modern eye surgeons can
sculpt the cornea with far less invasive
tools in corrective laser eye surgery
surgeons rely on excimer lasers these
tools are accurate enough to etch words
into a human hair to safely accomplish
these ultra fine incisions they use a
technique called photo ablation this
allows the lasers to essentially
evaporate organic tissue without
overheating surrounding eye tissue so
how does laser eye surgery actually work
the first step is to separate a thin
layer from the front of the cornea this
can be done with either a flat wide
blade or a femtosecond laser that
produces millions of tiny plasma bubbles
to create a plane beneath the corneal
surface surgeons then lift the flap to
expose the inside of the cornea guided
by the refractive error and the shape of
the cornea the excimer laser robotically
sculpts the exposed corneal bed into the
correct shape this process usually takes
less than 30 seconds for each eye
finally the flap is closed and its edges
reseal themselves in just a few hours
because the lasering is done on the
eyeball itself it's described as in situ
or on-site its complete name is laser in
situ keratomileusis but you probably
know it as lasik essentially this
technique carves a patient's contact
lens prescription onto their cornea like
any surgical procedure lasik comes with
certain risks some patients experience
slightly blurred vision that can't be
corrected by glasses but the technique
is currently about as likely to damage
your eyes as wearing daily disposable
contact lenses for one year today a
technique called smile enables surgeons
to sculpt the cornea through even
smaller incisions further reducing
recovery time
and lasers aren't just correcting the
three types of refractive errors this
technology can also restore aging eyes
in a technique called laser blended
vision surgeons adjust one eye to be
slightly better at distance vision and
the other to be better at close-range
vision the difference between the two
eyes is small enough that most patients
can merge their vision allowing both
eyes to work together at all distances
advances in laser technology continued
to make vision correction surgery more
effective and accessible
one day soon bada cares vision of a
world without glasses may finally come
true did you know that you're crying
right now our eyes are constantly
producing tears we go through 30 gallons
of Tears a year but not all tears are
the same get to know the three different
types with this video
[Music]